on le voit bien les femmes s'organise de
mieux en mieux pour défendre leurs
droits
elle observe en effet que la loi aussi
juste soit elle reste quelques fois
insuffisantes pour les protéger il
arrive que cette loi soit 6,1 en ou non
aux oubliés ou mal appliquées c'est le
cas par exemple pour l'avortement qui
fera l'objet demain à la sorbonne
d'états généraux
une quarantaine d'organisations y
participeront et elles veulent avant
tout dénoncer la dégradation de l'accès
à la contraception
depuis plusieurs mois plusieurs films ne
sont effectivement plus remboursés autre
sujet de préoccupation donc l'avortement
avec l'apparition des commandos anti ivg
le planning familial interviendra bien
sûr à ce propos nathalie darrigrand
dominique duchateau journée de
consultations au planning familial
laurence enceinte de cette semaine vient
pour l'entretien social indispensable à
toute demande d'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
une formalité pas question pour elle de
discuter sa décision on va discuter dans
ces cas là dans ces cas où vous ne
choisissez pas où il ya quelque chose
d'extérieur qui vous arrive de pied qui
vous arrive et qui n'est pas prévue et
puis de toute façon ma détermination et
l'été et que je n'ai pas les enfants
j'adore les enfants mais c'était un acte
qui me fallait
réaliser il faut que je réalise pas ce
que je n'ai pas du tout je ne suis pas
préparé laurence entrera en clinique la
semaine prochaine
son cas est simple presque classique les
choses se compliquent lorsque les jeunes
femmes dépassent le délai légal de 12
semaines
elles viennent alors au planning
chercher de l'aide on peut tout arriver
en deux mois en fait vous voyez un
moment dans trois mois
le papa est parti c'est vrai que c'est
assez quoi on n'a pas le temps de sorte
on aime faut prendre une décision assez
rapidement et c'est vrai que c'est
difficile
s'il faut partir à l'étranger je
partirai vous avez l'argent oui marie
christine et isabelle partiront donc à
londres tarif minimum trois mille francs
au planning depuis longtemps au milite
pour un allongement du délai de 12 à 15
semaines
allons nous espérons faire effectivement
déplacés un petit peu les délais jusqu
au moins 14 15 semaines
nous espérons avoir des médecins formés
pour accueillir les femmes dans l'essai
ivg nous espérons que une punition
important que s'abattra sur ce qui
empêche les femmes qui sont dans le
cadre de la loi d'avorter dernière
revendication le non remboursement de
certaines pilules
résultat les permanents du planning
reprennent le flambeau des militants
tout iront demain assister aux états
généraux